Bianca starts off this hour in Reno
Nevada hi Bianca how are you better than
I deserve what's up so for the last few
years I did a whole lot of stupid I just
found you about a month ago and on baby
steps - alright now I bought those 40
acres in the middle of Nevada and I am
building a cabin here but I'm on baby
steps - how do I go about allocating
some money so I can continue building
the cabin that I'm living in right now
okay so you're single okay so what's
your household income and how much debt
do you guys have about 40 and you don't
know anything on the cabin of the land
14,000 on the land and the cabin I got
pre-made exterior so is that included in
the 40 yes okay so 17 on the cabin and
land and 23 on everything else yes okay
and how much do you need to complete the
cabin okay so $60,000 makes you
debt-free with a completed cabin then
you make 92
mm-hmm so how fast how fast can you have
interesting stuff which is kind of
making its Moberly on my snowball not
really
you make 90 mm okay 92 minus 60 is 32 my
accounting taxes which we have to count
taxes but if you lived on 32 for one
year you would be debt-free and have the
been finished that's probably
unrealistic okay so let's just say you
did it in two years okay so how do I set
that up on my budget like do I take some
money out every month and put it on
towards the cabin or well let's just
let's talk it through for a second okay
if we need sixty thousand over two years
that means we need thirty thousand a
year that means we need two thousand
five hundred dollars a month towards our
program which includes fixing the cabin
and being a hundred percent debt free in
two years okay so you need $2,500 a
month you can do that make it 90 -
matter of fact you need to do better
than that that's a pretty lame okay I
want you to Jack that up let's say we
did three thousand what's your take home
pay right now okay so fifty six hundred
bucks a month okay yeah and can you live
on 2600 not counting your payments yes
you can actually the payments I need
okay pretty close
alright so let's keep working on that
but let's say that we put twenty five
hundred to three thousand dollars aside
now if we have I'm just gonna play with
some ratios here for a second if we need
twenty thousand and to the cabin and we
need forty thousand for the debt
one-third of your money's going to the
cabin and two-thirds is going to the
debt mm-hmm so if you did three thousand
dollars a month you put two thousand on
the debt and a thousand towards the
cabin every month every month and that
would mean you'd have to live on 2600
how big was your tax return last year
about 2800 is already adjusted so I
don't get a tax return next year you're
on it good oh good job good job okay
have you stopped your 401 K yes good
good you're on it you're doing good well
done so stupid is in your rear view
mirror I see wisdom out the windshield
you're doing good
yeah you're really doing good okay so
somewhere whatever number we come up
with or you come up with divide it by
three and put 2/3 towards your debt and
1/3 towards your cabin and live on the
rest so if you can figure out a way to
put 3,000 into this program and live on
2600 what you haven't quite got that yet
you started working on your budget but
you might get there or maybe you can
pick up some extra hours I don't know
whatever but salaries unfortunately yeah
well buddy you know what I'm saying the
the if we can figure out some way to add
a little bit to the equation you've
already done some good moves here and
maybe you can't but if you bit you know
say okay we can't do anything this month
because we need we need two thousand
dollars to do the next thing well you
say for two months you put $1,000 a
month and now you got two thousand
dollars and you do the two thousand
dollar item on the cabin meantime you
paid off four thousand dollars for the
debt two thousand each month okay so
three thousand bucks a month going into
this program makes you debt-free in a
finished cabin in two in twenty four
months let's do a ball that's doable you
can do that I mean you're cuz you're
already in this if you hadn't started
the process I would just say wait and
let's get out of debt and then go to the
cabin but you're square in the middle of
it so that keeps progress moving along
albeit gradually on the cabin and allows
you to really attack the debt and every
little bit of income that goes up you
know just start throwing it at this
program and do 2/3 1/3 2/3 1/3 2/3 1/3
and if you look up and you go okay we
got the cabin far enough I'm ready to
stop on it to lock out the rest of death
and reach over there and smack on that
debt for a couple of months it'll be
done then come back and you know dress
up the cabin or whatever at that point
so you can you can decide some give and
take on this some urban flow but
generally speaking you need 60,000 bucks
over two years or making 90 that's 30 a
year that's 2500 bucks a month you can
do this this is very doable
congratulations you have turned the
corner you're on your way I'm proud of
you